as we continue to observe black history
month it's hard to believe there are
still people alive today who had a
parent born into slavery daniel smith
who's almost 90 years old is one of the
few left jan crawford spoke with him
about his incredible story which
reflects the arc of race relations in
america from slavery to civil rights
activism and the fight to end systemic
discrimination jan is outside the
national museum of african-american
history and culture in washington a
great story today jan good morning
good morning michelle you know it's an
inspiring incredible story what's even
more incredible the messages that daniel
smith heard from his father a breed
slave survivor the strongest of the
strong so similar to what many other
children of freed slaves heard from
their parents it's a story history has
forgotten
we are survivors
daniel smith is one of the last living
links to america's original sin
your grandparents were enslaved right
your father was born the property of a
white man yep his father abram was born
into bondage in virginia in the early
1860s he was 70 when his youngest son
daniel was born he used to tell these
stories
stories about the inhumanity their
ancestors suffered and survived
father said you could hear him screaming
and crying
at the whipping post
but the interesting thing
my father
never allowed you
to talk negatively about
america his father believed like other
freed slaves in this new america his
young son would be great
he grabbed me and
shook me he said you have nothing to
nothing to cry about this is america we
came from the strongest of the strong we
survived the ships
the ship he gave me a signal to be
strong and to survive and not just
survive but thrive and fight for true
freedom john lewis
you have a lot of memories with him
right smith's living room is a testament
to his generation's struggle for
equality
he was there for martin luther king jr's
march on washington i want to remember
him someday little black boys and black
girls they work hand-in-hand with little
white boys and white girls and sisters
and brothers i have a dream today well i
was saying yes
and yes
smith followed that dream to alabama
where he helped lead the fight for
voting rights
he witnessed firsthand the terror smith
remembers the ku klux klan torching his
office and one night while driving a car
full of white men chased him down a dark
road
then all of a sudden boom they hit me
and so i sped up as fast as my
car would go and then they come along
beside me
pull over
you black
and i said no this black
not fallen over
because if they catch her
you're gone that must have been the most
terrifying i wasn't scared i was angry
but it stays with you up to 89. you know
like you can still feel that what were
you feeling
right smith went on to a successful
career in government
and then served as head usher at the
national cathedral where he led
presidents to prayer an incredible life
inspired by a generation history forgets
we want to think that happened so long
ago author santa butler says the
children of freed slaves like smith
heard similar messages from their
parents
mothers and fathers said we didn't
survive
for you to be anything other than great
in her book sugar of the crop butler
spoke to more than a dozen children of
slaves all of whom now are gone instead
of anger they were taught like smith
they could do anything after the civil
war
blacks truly believed the worst was over
the worst was over the worship is over
so they had this immigrant mentality
that we're going to go out and achieve
everything that we can
they didn't anticipate the barriers
white america would erect
but their message like the one from
smith's father was you are the strongest
of the strong people always say
it can't be done you can't do this you
can't do that i don't believe that if
you tell me that i'm going to do it you
hear people say today but america has
made so much progress it helps but
you know it really has when i
voted for obama i mean it was shaken i
couldn't believe i was doing this black
man
now we've made a lot of progress but he
says not nearly enough
we cannot continue as a
nation
with people hating each other my father
he never hated anyone you never saw that
from him right no never thought what
would your message be
for the future behind we need more
kindness i look back
in terms of my crazy life and i think it
all came from my father
saying do good things
do good things
now daniel smith turns 90 next month
he's planning to share his story in a
book that he's writing with his wife
loretta called son of a slave it's a
reminder that that dark chapter in
america's history is not that far in the
past tony
yeah jan i was just thinking that people
say it's ancient history but it can't be
that ancient when you have the the son
of a person uh who was born into bondage
right that person thought the future was
brighter for his son and it turns out
that was true but there's a lot of work
left to do jan thank you very much for
very skillful peace yeah skillful and so
reminds me of my father my grandmother
but the point that he made anger
is important it's what you do with the
anger
and how you make change with the anger
it's people get angry he said he was
angry yeah but it's like making that
constructive of course and he did it
throughout his life no doubt about it
and not every black person is
a descendant of someone who was enslaved
but if you are you are strong because
those before you yes were the strongest
of the strongest a lesson for a lot of
people you know it's like move move
beyond move forward and move forward
yeah
all right